good morning my name is Arielle Aria I'm
the CEO and president of a research
reagent company called stress mark
Biosciences and we specialize on making
tools for neurodegenerative disorders
and today my talk is going to be about
looking at the effects of sonication on
alpha-synuclein preformed liberals which
are one of the primary resources that we
use in order to create some of the
models that are required for this type
of research the sonication process
itself has been found to be absolutely
instrumental in a successful outcome in
terms of experimentation however the
effects of sonication themselves are
still a little bit of a mystery so I'm
going to start initially on an
introduction to alpha synuclein liberals
and look at some of the current best
practices followed by some information
on the key aggregation parameters and
then look some that some of the
information that we've generated in
terms of the sonication and track the
solubility of those liberals and finally
run through some of the conclusions now
office a nucleon is a small protein is
about 15 kilo daltons long 140 amino
acids long and it's physiological
function is not well understood but it
can act in a prion mic manner generating
a large family of oligomers which can
vary in size and structure and these can
then also go on to form fibular
constructs which look a little bit like
long strings the fibrillar as well as
oligomers have been found by a variety
of groups around the world to be toxic
to cells and furthermore the fibrin
selves can be processed particularly at
the c-terminal end resulting in
truncated constructs now in terms of the
actual disease alpha synuclein
oligomers and liberals can generate Lewy
bodies and neurites which are present in
Lewy body dementia which is a disease
often associated with Parkinson's and
these aggregates which I will show you
shortly
manifest themselves in the brain and
they also synonymous with Parkinson's
disease that killed brain cells and
unfortunately these aggregates can be
transmitted from cell to cell in a
variety of different ways and in fact
they're really quite stable entities
causing the disease to spread throughout
the brain now the concept of aggregation
is not unique to alpha synuclein there
are others such as a well known protein
such as a beta and tau which can also go
through a similar process and in fact
the alpha synuclein itself as a
proteinaceous seed can in fact also seed
other proteins to go through the same
sort of process including for instance
gamma synuclein the actual disease state
of synuclein APPA thiis as they're known
have no known cure and that would
include parkinson's but also diseases
such as multiple systems atrophy now on
this slide you will see a schematic
taken from Robertson brown from a few
years ago and it shows a very useful
schematic of how these processes work
and how they interact with each other
so we start with monomers and blue on
the left which can then go through a
variety of different processes
generating what are called on paths
oligomers which are in red in the middle
and these can vary in size and
properties and then we go on to form
these protofilaments which we would
probably generally also think certainly
at our neural laboratories as a soluble
filaments which look very much
Farrell's butter still in solution but
again have different properties to them
and then finally elongate into what we
know as these fibular aggregates there's
also the possibilities of having off
paths species and then some of these can
be toxic in nature whilst others can be
non-toxic there's also a real lack of
understanding of what happens in the
middle of this schematic and how many
oligomers and how many different types
there are and what their properties
might be and how they interact with each
other what is also clear is that there
is an element of equilibrium between
them so there is an interchange ability
here which makes the process more
complex the only situation that is
clearer is that the FIB rolls once they
fall out of solution and become a
suspension on the far right hand side
you drive this equation essentially to
the right now what does this look like
in real life well this is an image from
a brain of showing these these Lewy
bodies and knowing your rights the new
bodies themselves initially thought to
contain just alpha synuclein in fact do
contain a whole variety of different
things other proteins but even
organelles and membranes and all of
these can be stained with a phosphorus
specific antibody that is a specific to
alpha synuclein aggregation this is the
Lewy body pathology which is part of the
new ybody disease is a devastating
neurological disease how does it work
well the substantia [ __ ] which is part
of the brain that controls movement is a
place where alpha synuclein is present
and as you can see at the bottom these
monomers will aggregate into the mega
Marek forms
and as well as prote of liberals and
liberals and although it's not entirely
clear which species has high levels of
toxicities these will affect the
dopaminergic neurons and kill them and
as a result we see the movement
disorders that we associate with
Parkinson's disease such as the tremors
and so forth in terms of the protein
itself it's it's relatively small
protein but has some very interesting
aspects to it so you can see on the
left-hand side of this depiction that
there is a high degree of alpha helical
content and I draw your attention to the
federalization core and that's really an
area I referred to as the neck region
which is really instrumental in the
changing of this protein into a
different form and I mentioned earlier
that this is prion like what does that
mean and essentially what we're saying
is that this has the ability to self
catalyze from one form into another form
and generally we think of it as a benign
form into one that is disease-causing
however that's probably an over
simplification
regardless some other interesting
aspects of this protein and we'll go
into a little bit more detail in just a
moment is the mutation at position 53 so
that's what causes one of one of the
causes certainly a familial Parkinson's
disease and we find when we make those
sorts of liberals with the mutation at
position of 53 we find that material to
be very aggressive which is unsurprising
under the circumstances and there's also
a number of post translational
modifications which are of interest you
can see some of those there's four
tyrosines there that have undergone some
study they are not related but probably
by far the most interesting one is the
serine at position 129 this is
phosphorylated in living systems
and during the abrogation process so
it's a great way to monitor the
evolution of pathology generally if
these recombinant materials are used to
instigate to the pathology in a given
model system whether it sells or in vivo
or whatever and those materials are not
phosphorylated they're generally made in
eco line so any any pathology that is
visualized at a later stage will come
from endogenous material so this is a
schematic of again taken from the
reference cited below of where we start
with alpha-synuclein with this alpha
helical content then going through a
variety of different changes governed by
energy etc and ending up with this beta
sheet content and that is a great boon
to scientist because we can measure the
evolution of this beta sheet content
relatively simply and if we have a look
at this sort of typical graph that looks
a little bit like enzymatic reaction
with an initial rate here and so forth
we can see the evolution of the blue
line as it goes up and that's the beta
sheet that is being created from the
alpha heel alpha helix during this prom
like reaction and here what we have done
is we've taken the seeds of alpha
synuclein and we've added more monomer
and these seeds dramatically accelerate
the reaction so that there's essentially
no lag time and we can see here that the
blue line takes off really rather
rapidly and you can imagine that this is
a excellent sort of assay that you might
want to screen inhibitors for because
it's a very simple way to see whether or
not you would depress that back rate or
bring it to a halt all together
now without wanting to go into too much
detail I want to emphasize the fact that
there are a variety of different types
of monomers and oligomers and filaments
and fib roles which can all get a little
bit complicated often it describes their
activities and their structures but
sometimes also in part their
surroundings because it's the
surroundings that ultimately dictate
what type of structure these will adopt
so we have here at stress mark would
provide generally two types of monomers
what we refer to as type 1 and type 2
which ultimately will generate type 1 or
type 2 their goals there's also various
types of oligomers they can be made in
several ways but we generally see them
and we'll look at them shortly to be
roughly 25 nanometers in diameter and
then of a globular nature filaments are
what we would think is most people
thinking of proto fibrils but we call
them filaments because these are
essentially products that are
intermediates
so once the oligomeric forms have begun
to elongate into filaments which are
these long string like structures again
which we'll have a look at in just a
moment they go through a process by
which the beta-sheet content is not as
high as it is with the fibrillar AAPA
bit they are still soluble so they do
have different properties although if
you do leave them to continue
aggregating they will as subsequently
formed liberals and then we have the
pebbles themselves I'm not going to
spend too much time on Type three
because it's really in a way a hybrid of
type 1 and 2 but type 1 and type 2 again
quite different in terms of leadership
content and also differential properties
in biological systems this is a
schematic that gives you an idea of
roughly how difficult it is to determine
what's what on the top left-hand corner
we have type 1 febrile
these would be the ones
that are overwhelmingly used in
scientific research and these generates
a lot of pathology for instance and have
high tht fluorescence values type 2 is
quite different very little study with
this and does not show a lot of
pathology as we'll see in just a moment
type 3 I'm not going to worry about too
much at this stage I think the key of
the point is it's made differently and
yet under e/m these are of course all
electron micrographs look very very
similar to the others and then finally
the filaments in the bottom right-hand
corner again looking quite similar to
the others in some instances
particularly on the top left type one
and in some of the other micro so you
can see the association between between
Federal's because they are sometimes in
effectively in duplexes and in other
cases on just single single rods
now the oligomers look quite different
you may recall earlier I said they
resemble these globular structures
roughly circular or so and there it's
very easy to discern them from from the
pimples themselves and their properties
again are quite different they don't see
as a general rule and these weren't used
with dopamine which is probably the most
physiologically relevant chemical that
we could induce them with given the
activity of these constructs in the
brain and they also they so they don't
seed and yet they have a quite high
level of toxicity associated with them
now in terms of alpha-synuclein
first two types of liberals if you look
at this typical seeding assay you'll see
in purple the very aggressive increase
in fluorescence as the type 1 febrile is
made just below it you'll see it going
at maybe 20
twenty-five percent of that level of
activity is a type two febrile now the
type two liberal and the type one
liberals have in terms of their
generation the exact same parameters
being associated with them so they have
the same type of Mon Amour associated
with them and the same amounts the same
concentrations temperatures et cetera
but what this clearly shows you is that
the type two liberal has a much much
lower beta sheet content than the type
one now this is manifest also in the
biological sphere so this is work that
is done in done in primary rat cells new
cortical cells and you can see on the
left-hand side in the middle when using
a phosphorous hearing 129 antibody that
can detect the phosphorylated endogenous
pathology that's been generated in those
cells you'll see when we treat with the
type 1 we get a lot of pathology which
is the green picture in the middle
however if we use type 2 we get
essentially nothing now these are
relatively short-term experiments of
course type 2 has not been particularly
well studied for the simple reason but
it's generally at least at this point in
time less interest to the scientific
community principally because the gold
standard is seen as that which creates a
lot of pathology but clearly there are
different types that do different things
now what do these actually look like
well these are post sonication
preformed fib roles on the left hand
side we have human ones on the right
hand side we have mouse ones Mouse ones
generally are seems being more
aggressive in nature when used in
cellular or in vivo assays however the
concept is the same you'll see that
these are roughly in the 30 to 70
nanometer range they in deep clumped
quite well they're quite uniform
and when these are then subsequently
injected into rat brains for instances
this is a work that was done at a cro
the alpha-synuclein pathology again
measured using the phosphorus serine 129
antibody the the pathology is generated
throughout the brain and on the top left
hand side you can see the the ipsy para
form but what's interesting about this
is that right below it you see the
Contra side so this is not just
something that happens at site injection
this does spread throughout the
injection very clearly generates the
pathology and this is of course of
critical importance because for those
that are wanting to try treatments or
drug mission regimens to attenuate the
process of aggregation and the evolution
of this pathology you have to create the
model in order to test those those
methods or candidates and I think in
this case the the time that is used for
this experiment is only 30 days so it's
a very fast way of generating a model
whereas if you were to use transgenic
animals for instance this could take
many months now in terms of the best
practices the best practices as a good
solid general rule have been very well
defined by the Michael J Fox foundation
have been absolutely instrumental and
quite extraordinary in fact in terms of
the input that they have placed from a
research perspective and an information
dissemination perspective for
Parkinson's disease and other associated
diseases in this field the actual
handling requirements of the preformed
liberals are
indicated very clearly in the reference
cited at the bottom which is only about
18 months older so at this point and the
key elements that come from from that
publication are that you need to
sonicator those immediately before use
and that it's the you know the active
component itself is unclear however it's
deemed to be short rib rolls or
oligomers that are made in the process
now the size of those which is a really
really key element of that publication
and others of course is that the size
must be about 50 nanometers in length or
smaller to generate the successful
phosphorus here in 129 pathology and if
you don't do that or if you have larger
ones then this is the success of the
experiment is in question and you will
not generate or the experiment that will
fail the there is no negative impact
interestingly extending the sonication
time so you use essentially what you're
saying is what we're saying is we can't
overdo it and by that same token there
appear to be no differences in a monoid
conformation or if they're both
structure if we Sonic eight in other
words the femoral is still the FIB role
despite the fact that it is shorter but
it is absolutely key and well understood
that these shorter fibrillar are more
efficient in terms of the seeding and
their use in vitro and in vivo
now the sonication process being as
violent as it is may negatively affect
the stability simply because of the heat
generators so they do request that
cooling is required so in if we
summarize that briefly the effects of
sonication as we know them is that they
reduce the size the febrile into smaller
segments which we know to be true it D
clumps the fib roles which we know to be
true and there's also probably a very
intuitive because they are in suspension
they're not insufficient so they do
clump together
and we also know and this is very very
key that we get a very very
significantly higher activity when we
add sonicate or properly sonicated
materials PFF materials to cells were
used in vivo and the actual difference
can be quite extreme it can really spell
the difference between success and
failure of the experiment so our
question really was here is is something
else occurring and this really was
reflection of the phase status of these
experiments now I went back to work that
I had done at MIT with professor
klebanov back in the early to mid 90s
where we did something profoundly
different and yet with a few possible
parallels to the situation with PFS when
we use PFS they are in soluble
aggregates and yet the substrate that is
used to create them is in solution now
alexander kononov pioneered the use of
dried enzyme preparations in non aqueous
media usually to carry out a variety of
hydrolysis or esterification Zoar
transesterification x' and by changing
different parameters such as the
surrounding in Europe he was able to
change both enantioselective ities of
enzymes or vitro specificities of
enzymes and so forth and so I looked at
some of the key criteria that at the
laboratory and that we used to look at
in those days and because we had one key
element that we needed to try to answer
and that was why are those reactions so
incredibly slow they you can definitely
do interesting things but the actual
speed of reaction can be up to a
millionfold slower than it is in water
now again very different situation to
what we have with timbrels and yet we
know that we dramatically slow down the
reaction
the Iraq with if we if we don't Sonic
eight so we I wondered whether there
were some parallels here so I looked at
a variety of different criteria that we
examined at the time and I've listed
them here you'll see them all in red and
one in white the ones in red are ones I
don't believe pertained such as
diffusional limitations I mean we're
using water so there shouldn't be any
diffusional limitations through the
media and we're not really using enzymes
so the active center of blockage as well
conformational changes that may result
during the drying process might relevant
here as well as the transition state
destabilization and reduce conformation
with mobility or not relevant because
we're not drawing enzymes neither is
this a Baltimore pH situation because
again we're in water however there is
this possibility of unfavorable
energetics of substrate D salvation
because we know that's what happens we
know that a monomeric form of
alpha-synuclein goes from the fully
solvated state to a desolated state in
the fibrin and herein lies our question
if the sonication process doesn't just
chop your bra's up or make them shorter
if in fact it has an impact on
solubility or salvation of the fibrils
then could be much more successful on
higher rates of reaction that we see
after we have conducted our sonication
process
b-joo not just two shorter liberals but
the fact that we may be placing the
entire experimental setup into one phase
rather than two phases so rather than
having a solvated substrate and a d
solvated product maybe we're putting
everything into solution so we had a
look and to see if that might be the
case because
if indeed everything was in one phrase
then the unfavorable energetics of the
substrate deceleration would be
eliminated because it wouldn't exist
because everything would be in solution
and that increase in problem like
activity that we see would of course
increase and that is also known to occur
so does sonication create a single-phase
system what we thought we'd have a go
and so we took some of our fib rose
alpha synuclein fibrillar and this is
what they looked like pre sonication
and the mean size here is just under 70
nanometers and I'm not going to show you
every single step that we did but just a
few of them but as we increased
sonication we began to see just as we
would expect defibrillating smaller so
this is down to 52 nanometers and then
finally as we increase time and of
course amplitude down to just under 40
nanometers now if we look at this in a
bar graph format we can see more or less
what we'd expect sort of a linear
relationship as we increase the time
and/or power of sonication we decrease
the size of the federals that's
well-known and well-understood the
question is was anything else happening
what was happening to the solubility of
these so we ran sedimentation assays and
as you can see on the far left hand side
the two yellow arrows show the amount of
material that are in this soluble and
insoluble phases and on the far left you
see in the supernatant there's a little
bit but in the pallet there's the best
overwhelming majority now that begins to
change as we sonic it and in our most
aggressive sonication protocol on the
far right hand side you'll see that
everything has moved into the soluble
phase into the supernatant and nothing
indeed is left in the pallet now what
happens over time
because is this just a transient
situation but if again you look at the
highlighted areas on the right-hand side
which is representative of our most
aggressive sonication method in yellow
you'll see the difference going from
July to October in in our pellet and
then looking at our supernatants after
storing those materials for four months
or so at minus eighty you see that the
materials stay in solution so they do
not revert now that has a number of
implications that are contrary to
current thinking because it suggests
that you could sonicator prepare
materials and then for instance ship
them elsewhere and that you don't
actually need to sonicate directly prior
to an experiment it also suggests that
whatever we're doing is quite permanent
and that the likelihood of something
like that could be something like a
covalent modification now we were kind
enough to receive some work that was
also done by the Andrew West lab in the
States and they were working on sonic
ating some of our favorites
and this work sort of complements what
we've been looking at and if if if we
look at the results using dynamic light
scattering of sonic KT alpha synuclein
Liberals directly and quite aggressively
they seem to be able to get them down to
a size of about just over 20 nanometers
which is really quite small
interestingly if you do the same with
garrison you clean that's not the case
and further sonication doesn't change
this and it has a much broader and
distribution and much longer fibrils
furthermore beta synuclein it's a
similar sort of outcome quite broad and
again more sonication
doesn't actually do anything now these
are all quite heavily related to each
other with a lot of sequence homology so
again we thought we'd use a different
sonication protocol and just have a look
at what was happening from
solubility perspective this is using a
cup corn system which at least in our
case is far less efficient than using
the probe because we're not in direct
content with the pro head however you
can see on the left-hand side we have
begun to push some of the material from
the the control side into that was
originally the palate into the
supernatant just as we would expect
however Peter synuclein appears to
already be in solution which is
something which we had not realized when
making meter synuclein Farrell's this is
an protein that does not liberalize
readily at all you can try to federalize
it even for a year you without success
what you do need is you really need to
hit it with the proverbial sledgehammer
and use metal ions and so forth to
induce it to liberalise which are then
of course subsequently removed after the
food rolls are formed so they are
excellent controls in that regard but it
does seem that they are already in
solution and hence don't really benefit
from the sonication process because they
don't need it now on the final side of
gamma synuclein we see very little
effect at all that the sonication
process doesn't really seem to do much
of anything now we had a look at the
sequences and mined them up and I just
want to highlight the read encapsulation
on the sequence at the top and there we
see that's part of the neck region which
is missing and Beata synuclein which is
why it doesn't fit relies because the
area is missing however it's also quite
a hydrophobic area and so our hypothesis
is at this point that that is the
absence of that section is actually
sufficient and makes the resulting
protein pebbles sufficiently polar that
they will actually naturally without any
further help go into solution if we look
in a little bit more detail at what
happens
with Gama synuclein the major changes at
the c-terminal area and what I've done
is I've highlighted some of the residues
in that area just the Metheny it's
entirely tyrosines
which can undergo oxidative reactions
and if we step back a moment and think
about just how aggressive sonication
processes are with the little bubbles
that are formed and the high
temperatures that are generated when
they collapse you can imagine there's a
lot of reactive oxygen species that are
generated and I'm wondering whether just
the oxidation of for instance the the
for tyrosine in that c-terminal area
which represents to a large degree the
changes between these these two proteins
if that is enough that oxidation is
enough to push this into solution
because they'd be able to form more
hydrogen bonds and could be a more proto
construct now one way in which we tried
finally to test this was to just treat
it at a higher pH so we took these
nucleons emeralds and we also put them
into a buffer at pH 10 for an hour on
the basis that there are sufficient
hydroxyl ions there that if there's
something for them to find they would
probably do that and if our hypothesis
was right there should be some movement
of the insoluble material into soluble
material and interestingly that's
exactly what we see and that would also
of course explain the longevity of the
sonication process so we may be looking
at not just physical aspects of
sonication but arguably chemical side
effects of sonication which lead to this
sony solubilization of these liberals
so in conclusion therefore
the sonication of alpha-synuclein
preformed pimples results in pebbles
moving from the insoluble to the soluble
phase and it's likely that the dramatic
increase in solubility removes or
reduces the limitations that are seen
with prion like activity if that is not
carried out and it's quite possible that
the limitations may be due to this
unfavorable energetics and that are
removed by sonication which are a
function of the monomer desolvation
into pimples there is no doubt that PFS
are intact reduced in size June
sonication that is definitely a truth
and that the federal science change may
still be a good indicator of whether or
not
sonication has happened properly however
probably the best way in the simplest
and certainly cheapest way to identify
the Liberals properly sonicated is to
carry out a sedimentation assay and see
if in fact they have been dissolved also
the Liberals stay in solution for at
least 3-4 months when stored at minus 80
and I suspect significantly longer
because it appears that it's likely that
we are in fact going through a chemical
reaction as well the sonication process
is highly aggressive and does generate
the oxidative stress including the
generation of free radicals and the
possibility that we looked at that the
free radical generated modification of
liberals plays an instrumental role in
the increasing solubility of
alpha-synuclein preformed liberals
that's as far as i'm going to take this
the I'd like to acknowledge a few people
before I finish Alexandre Network
legumes the head of our laboratory was
instrumental in planning of some of
these experiments Sofie Sun was directly
involved in carrying out the experiments
and we'd like to thank Andrew West and
his laboratory for the data that they
provided to us which was complementary
to this work
thank you very much